miss france se fait salement miss france
comment s'appelle miss france d'ailleurs
en ce moment tino bottineau exactement
est vrai les meilleurs en miss france
quand géopolitique miss france se fait
salement assez horrible ce fait salement
bottineau oui si l'on fait salement
recaler d'un buffalo grill se fait
salement recalé à buffalo grill
tu dois vous c'est peut-être votre
émission de l'année non vraiment ce fait
socialement quoi c'est faire ça ils
m'ont insulté salma insulter c'est un
peu ça à les critiquer je prends benhaim
pour son sixième point alors qu'il n'y a
eu que quatre questions
les rêves de femmes a mis sa croissance
s'est fait insulter clémence bottineau
qui a été miss france 2000 vendée en
décembre dernier mushkin assala elle a
été élue miss france sera mauvais a dit
non mais la cour a vraiment et on n'aura
pas vu de l'année elle n'aura pas vu de
l'année elle n'a pas mangé une tranche
de saucisson dans une foire l'air non
mais ça rigolait pas ça la une non
messieurs
la pauvre alors juste ici si en plus on
lève la main c'est par williams à
miliciens m'a rendu compte que oui ben
vous allez voir vous allez voir
comparaison sur le voyage sur les
voyages tu as raison elle a pensé
qu'elle allait faire un tour du monde
qu'elle avait voyagé partout en france
et puis elle est restée dans un
appartement il succombe à lui-même of mr
c'est pas parce que c'est miss france
qu'elle a des paroles a été confiné
comme tout le monde elle était chez elle
avec la couronne mais en plus je
l'adorent elle est très belle et elle
était très sympathique clémence
moi j'ai envie de te laisser clémence
une année de plus voilà mais savait
qu'il en est et qui m'est avis qu'ils
ont misé âgées abandonnées de faire
durer son élection plus on formerait pas
de miss france elle reste on est
deuxième elles sont comme ça enfin qu'il
faut il ya des côtés je ne peux pas
l'autre il existe le regarder c'est
comme vous l urbain en 2006 a été mis
jeudi à bas un jour elle n'a pas pu
aller au congrès du couscous et ben
c'est fatima boîte
l'année où j'ai gardé les soirs 2000
france regarde l'avenir c'est que
clémence bottineau n'aura pas eu
beaucoup de chance seulement trois mois
après avoir remporté la fameuse couronne
du concours miss france le pays a été
confiné et elle n'a pas pu profiter de
son règne
sauf qu'au moment où le gouvernement a
annoncé le confinement obligatoire de
tous les français elle se trouvait en
guadeloupe dans sa famille impossible
donc pour elle de rentrée c'est donc il
ya quelques jours seulement avec la
levée du confinement que la jeune femme
a pu regagner paris pour reprendre son
activité sauf que voilà
suite à l'annoncé de ce retour certains
internautes se sont montrés critiques
donc elle peut prendre l'avion alors que
des français expatriés sont bloqués quel
intérêt il ya je pense d'autres
préoccupations que miss france mais on
n'a pas le droit d'aller plus loin de
100 km si je me trompe pas des
techniques très vite démonter par sylvie
tellier
si la question des expatriés ne se pose
pas étant donné que la guadeloupe est
française pour ce qui est des
déplacements la présidente du comité
miss france a expliqué vous êtes
nombreux à nous demander pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle rende clémence de guadeloupe et
bien parce que aujourd'hui clément salée
elle est salariée l'organisation miss
france
son travail est ici à paris décidément
cette année de miss ne commence pas sous
les meilleurs auspices et oued avait une
histoire de miss france machine à sa
mission et enfin ça me fait appel moi
j'aime bien me sa j'adore
on la trouve très sympathique ouais
franchement oui ouais tu m'en soucier
déranger le sait pas qui chantera des
papilles en mai bennani mon nom mais je
voulais participer je suis à m'occuper
de toi chaque instant série ne lâche pas
nouveau et moi on est comme ça je sais
je sais